Her low freak bitches.
What about the idea is that the universe
is in a constant state of contraction
and expansion? Well, no.
It's up and abandoned.
Some physicist to argue that it's,
there's a cycle because it looks nice and
they are. I think most of most people,
I mean there's some people
who were arguing for that.
I don't find that pictures well,
I think they're trying to
type their ignorance and
something that isn't any more
plausible in that picture. That expands
forever and as far as we can tell,
the most likely possibilities that are
universal expand forever fought to make
you a little bit happier.
It's quite possible. The best
pictures that we have of,
of, of, of the early universe is that
we actually, our universe isn't unique,
isn't alone.
That there are many universes,
we call it a multiverse and that at any
instant in time and kind of a cosmic
super time,
there's always universe being born
so that that multi-verse might be,
might be infinite and eternal.
Where are they outside of our universe?
How's that even possible? How of course
it's possible. I understand. Okay.
Well, first of all, the
simplest possibility is that
they're outside the region.
We can see right for, for, for example,
the edge is our visible universe.
Space is expanding faster away from
us than light because you know,
we taught you in school and nothing
can travel faster than light.
You may remember that from
school. We lied. Okay, well no,
you have to parse it more carefully.
Like a lawyer.
Nothing could travel through
space faster than light,
but space can do whatever the hell it
wants. So locally, as I told you though,
radio host is,
is at rest they're not moving.
And and the other end of the galaxy at
the other end of the visible universe and
we're rest, but the space between
us is expanding. So that galaxy,
like a surfer is being carried away from
us faster than light relative to the
water, the surfers and moving.
Right. But relative to the shore,
the surfer is right, right. Okay. So this,
this galaxy is not moving relative
to its local surroundings,
but it's moving away from us faster than
light. And like a surfer in an undertow,
they can swim really fast in the water,
but if the water's moving
away from the shore,
they'll never make it back to the
shore. Right. And so that galaxy,
the light from that galaxy is traveling
through space at the speed of light.
But it's the space in between us and
the galaxies moving faster than light.
Then the poor light can ever make
it to us. We call that a horizon.
Wow.
So the space is traveling too far
for the light to reach us so fast.
The triple spaces too fast.
So this light can't catch up
with the expansion of space
and it never gets to us.
And that that galaxy disappears
from our causal horizon.
We call it will never be able to see it.
We'll never be able to interact with it
will never be okay. And it could be that,
that there are different
regions so far away from us.
We're space is expanding
faster than light, which,
which have a very different
history than our own.
So there could be space,
could be infinite,
just our simple unit space that we know
of and love could be infinite in extent
and different regions of that space had
different histories and some of those
regions, everything we can see we
know emerged from a single point.
Okay.
We can tell that.
We can tell that by measuring big bang
expansion of everything we see and
working backwards and the university,
our visible universe was once
smaller and smaller and smaller.
If you go back in time,
we can actually follow the laws of physics
back to the earliest moments of the
big bang until those laws break down
and we can make predictions about the
university.
It looked like all his predictions agree
exactly what the observations we make,
which tell us that that picture works,
but another region if you wish,
could have come from a different big bang,
but is that another universe or
is it a part of the university?
Here's how we've changed and this is
semantics, but nontrivial semantics,
namely when I was a kid, universe
meant every everything, right?
But we say that's pretty
stupid definition.
A better definition is an operational one.
Universe means that region of space
with which at one time we could have
communicated or one time in the future,
even if the future is infinite,
we might communicate with cause that
describes the region of space where cause
and effect works some measurable distance.
Yes.
And so that are we think of a universe
is that region which could throughout
which everything could affect everything
else ultimately in an infinitely long
time.
And in that picture,
universities can be restricted in size
and then other regions which could never
have affected us and which will
never affect us in the future.
We call other universes.
Uh, and when, and,
and now there are many different
versions of a multiverse,
but that's the simplest version. And
this picture we call inflation, which,
uh, you know, I talk, I just did two
little clips associated with the new book,
one force for a publisher and one
was for big. Think one is, uh,
the universe in under two minutes.
So you can look up online,
look for Lawrence Krauss,
explains the universe in under two
minutes where I talk about this cosmic
expansion and how it might mean there's
a multiverse. But the other is, um,
I explained the universe in terms of this
beer bottle that I talked about to you
earlier. So you can, that's a
video, you can watch that. But it,
this theory of inflation, which
actually says are universal. The qual,
the qualities that we see of our universe
can best be explained if some early
time in the history of the universe when
it was a billionth of a billionth of a
billionth of a billionth of a second old.
It had a huge expansion
suddenly and increased in
size by 30 orders of magnitude
in size, in a billionth of a billionth of
a billionth of a billionth of a second.
Which is by the way, particle physics
suggests is highly plausible even though,
okay. And then, and then,
and then it would produce a universe
that looks more or less like we look like
you look like and and uh,
and it,
and it's right now the only explanation
of what of how that would cause the
universe to look like,
what it looks like.
But the neat thing about
inflation is it's eternal.
So inflation that puffing up and in
our universe and then boom, a hot,
big bang followed it. Okay.
So the region, universe,
universe puffed up by huge amount than
all of that energy which was stored in
empty space, got released like in
the beer bottle and we got a hot,
Big Bang and the rest is history,
but that's locally.
But somewhere else between us in their
space is still expanding exponentially
and faster and faster and faster and
only maybe somewhere else today. Boom.
Like an ice crystal forming boom,
that that region of space is suddenly
left inflation and maybe a guilt a
gazillion years in the future,
there'll be another region of space
that's expanding away from a summit much
faster than light. So we'll never
know about it. We're suddenly,
that region needs inflation and
boom, another hot, big bang happens.
And it turns out in each of those hot,
big bangs, after the inflation ends,
depending upon how it ends,
the laws of physics could be
different in that universe.
And that's how we tend to think.
It's quite likely that there are many,
many separate regions of space.
And in fact, it's eternal.
So such regions are forming eternally
for all time and, and, and there are hot,
big bangs happening in many regions and
the properties of each of those regions,
whether they're conducive to forming
galaxies and stars and planets and people
may be different.
So we could say logically in that picture,
that the reason the universe looks like
the way it does is because we're here to
measure it.
Oh my God,
we should leave it at that.
Okay. We should close with that.
That is the mind blower of one blowers.
Good.